FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WITH THIRTY EIGHT BILLS
CONSIDER THIS MORNING AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO COVER.
I'D LIKE TO THINK AT SOME POINT
MR MCCARTY MISTER STONE FOR
JOINING THE COMMITTEE TODAY I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
PRESIDENT THAT WERE STILL
REQUIRED TO WEAR A MASK. WILL
ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT- ON ANY
BILL THAT'S PLACED ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE- WHERE THAT THE
MEMBER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
I'M BE REALLY CLEAR TODAY. WE
HAVE NO LEAVE WITNESSES THAT
MEANS ANYONE WHO WANTS TO.
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO A BILL THESE ARE
THE RULES YOU GET TO SAY YOUR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
BELONG TO A CANNOT EXCEED FIVE
WORDS IF YOUR ORGANIZATION
EXCEEDS FIVE WORDS WHEN I ASK
YOU TO PUT THAT IN WRITING TO
GIVE IT TO THE COMMITTEE. SO
YOU CAN BRING IT DOWN TO FIVE
WORDS. AND YOUR POSITION THAT'S
ALL YOU CAN TESTIFY TO DATE- WE
APPRECIATE. EVERYBODY'S
ISSUANCE OF A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THOSE ARE THE RULES
YOU BREAK THE RULES YOU WILL BE
WARNED IF YOU'RE WORN TWICE
BREAKING THE RULES YOU GET ONE
MORE WARNING AND THIRD TIME
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET YOU SPEAK
ANYMORE SO. THOSE ARE THE RULES
ARE GONNA BY BY TODAY HOPE YOU
DO TOO. WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO MISTER DODD BECAUSE
HE'S HERE. AND IT'S GONNA BE AN
EASY- WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM YET
DO WE- WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN- WE HAVE
QUORUM AND ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MISTER DIED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THIS BILL IT'S BEEN A
GREAT WORK IN PROGRESS FOR THE-
WATER RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO-
CONTRACT OUT WE'VE HAD. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AMEND THE BILL
MANY TIMES WE'RE STILL WORKING
WITH THE CVC ON SOME ISSUES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE FOR CALL IN- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THE PHONE NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN WITHOUT WILL GO TO- THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
SENATOR DODDS SB SIX TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SIX TWO SIX. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWO SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK I SEE
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK- IS A REMOTE. SITE
TODAY I SEE NOBODY THERE IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOMEONE.
THE ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SOURCES. GEN YES
GOOD MORNING CHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER BIGELOW AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MILLION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELL WE
HAVE NO POSITION ON SB SIX
TWENTY SIX WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ESTIMATES AN INITIAL MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACT FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PROCESSES
AND PROCEDURES FOR IMPLEMENTING
THE NEW PROJECT. WHAT IS DOUBLE
EDGED. THERE WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS
RESULTING FROM A MORE
EXPEDITIOUS DELIVERY OF CERTAIN
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I THOUGHT WE HAD A QUORUM PER
SECOND THERE BUT SOMEBODY
ESCAPED. SO WITH THAT WE WILL-
TAKE UP A MOTION OF A- SENATE
DIED SOON AS WE HAVE QUORUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PER SHARE.
OKAY I THINK WE HAVE QUORUM NOW.
AND SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GONZALEZ PRESENT
BIGELOW BRIAN CALDERON CORREO
CHAO DOLLY DAVIES FONG GABRIEL
THERE WERE GARCIA. STONE FOR
LIVING WORK HERE ROBERT RIVAS
WEBER MCCARTY VACANCY. HE. ALL
RIGHT- WITH THAT I'LL TAKE A
MOTION FROM MISS CALDERON A
SECOND BY MR STONE AND I SOON
AS WE GET A FEW MORE DEMOCRATS
HERE THAT WILL BE OUT. THANK
YOU. MISTER HERTZBERG SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO ENJOYS A- DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. YOU MAY PROCEED-
THIS MEASURE IS A CREATIVE WAY
TO GIVE AN EXPEDITED PROCESS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER INSTEAD
OF RECORDING AN ABSTRACT OF
JUDGMENT THEY CAN GO DIRECTLY
SAVES A LOT OF TIME AVOIDS US
IMPACT TO BY UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS OR TRICKING TO GET
OUT FROM UNDER THEIR LIABILITY
I ASKED RELIABLE. THANK YOU-
WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION EITHER I THINK YOU
SAID SUPPORT BUT WE TAKE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OKAY AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NOBODY IN THE QUEUE. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU BRING IT BACK I
SEE NOBODY- YOU'RE WANTING TO
SPEAK. THE PART A NOBODY UP ON
THE REMOTE STATION DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THANK YOU HAVE A
VISION OF THE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS DOES
NOT ANTICIPATE THIS BILL TO
HAVE A FISCAL IMPACT THOUGH
THERE MAY BE FUTURE SAVINGS
FROM A STREAMLINED PROCESS FROM
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A- WE HAD A MOST
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE OTION
BY MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY
MR STONE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL TAKE THAT UP-
AS SOON AS WE GET OUR WE HAVE
ENOUGH. ALL RIGHT CHECK IT OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER HERTZBERG. WITH MR
BIGELOW WITH MISS DAVIES VOTING
I MISTER PHONE CODE. THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MISS
DAVIES AND- MR FONG BODHI NINE.
ON THE DODD BILL THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MISS
DAVIES NOT VOTING IN AND MR
FONG THIRTY NINE. ALL RIGHT WE
GOT TO BILLS DOWN TWO TO GO IF
WE GET AN AUTHOR HERE AT THIS
TIME I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MOVED BY. DR
QUIRK IN SECOND BY MISS DAVIES
KEY PLEASE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SB SEVEN TO EIGHT
HERTZBERG SB FOUR FIVE THREE
YEAR TITLE SB FOUR EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT FOUR JONES AS HE SAID
FIVE SEVEN FOUR LAYERED. SB TWO
SIX NINE PORTANTINO SB TWENTY
SIX SKINNER SB TWO THREE NINE
PM BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS SB EIGHT ONE
THREE. MILLION GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SB EIGHT ONE FOUR
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION SB
EIGHT TO FOUR COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. THANK
YOU- I JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
STAFFS OF MISS SKINNER AND
MISTER BRADFORD- THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PROCEED WITH THE REST
OF THE HEARING BUT IF WE DON'T
GET SOMEBODY HERE WE WILL HAVE
TO MOVE THESE BILLS TO THE NEXT
SCREEN WHICH IS AFTER THE BREAK.
THANK WOULD WANT THIS DONE. I'M
WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
READ THE- BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB
SEVEN FIVE TWO ALLEN S. B. TWO
SIX EIGHT ARCHULETA SB FOUR
FOUR FIVE FOUR BATES SB SIX A
BACKER SB FIVE NINE SIX BAKER
SB THREE A THREE BORJAS. SB SIX
TO DORADO SB FOUR OH THREE
GONZALEZ AS BEFORE WHEN SIX
WESO SB ONE AWAIT OR TADO SB
SIX NINE OR TITLE SB FIVE THREE
FIVE EIGHT JONES SP FOUR SEVEN
ZERO JONES. SB FOUR NINE SIX
LAYARD S. B. TWO ONE FIVE LEYVA
SB TWO NINE SIX LIMóN S. B.
TWO SIX SIX NEWMAN S. B. TWO
SIX THREE RUBIO. SB TWO FIVE
THREE EIGHT RUBIO S. B. SIX
SEVEN EIGHT RUBIO SB EIGHT ONE
SKINNER SB SIX NINE THREE STERN
SB THREE THREE NINE WIENER.
THOSE BILLS ARE MADE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE IS STILL SEE NO
SENATOR- AT THIS POINT WE WILL
GO AHEAD TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY
BILL. THAT WAS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE YOU MAY DO SO NOW
WELL LET BEFORE WE GO THERE
OPERATOR I'M SORRY TO SEE THAT
MISS SKINNER AND MISTER
BRADFORD SHOWED UP THIS IS
GREAT WE'RE GONNA GO QUICK. MY
HAVE RECORD TIME. MISS GET OF
MISTER MISCONDUCT. SB TWO
NINETY ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WE HAVE A
MOTION. BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISS DAVIES YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH DEJA
VU. BILL EXACTLY LIKE LAST
YEAR'S. PASSED BY SIXTY SEVEN
VOTES ON THE ASSEMBLY FOR I
COULD EXPLAIN IT BUT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE- PHONE
LINES FOR SB TWO NINETY ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
MY NUMBERS. NINE TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
VOLUME BUTTON BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE ATTRACTED HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA YIMBY THE
SAN FRANCISCO PLANNING AND
URBAN REACHED PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH THAT PATIENT
OFTEN ON A BURKE AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION FOR CBI. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE'LL GO TO I SEATED IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS MCKAY LEE ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF CENTER
SKINNER'S BILL THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I
SEE NOBODY AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BILL ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST AND SECOND YEAR FOR A
HALFTIME POSITION FOR A TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM TO
INVESTIGATE VIOLATIONS PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND DRAFT
ENFORCEMENT CORRESPONDENCE THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO NOTES
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS MAY BE REQUIRED DUE
TO OVERALL INCREASED WORKLOAD.
FINANCE NOTES IT IS UNCLEAR
WHETHER THE WORKLOAD REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE AN
ADDITIONAL POSITION. THAT COULD
NOT OTHERWISE BE ABSORBED WELL
THE BILL MAY RESULT IN LOCAL
COSTS. FINANCES NOT ANTICIPATE
THE BILL TO CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN LEVY
SERVICE CHARGES FEES AND
ASSESSMENTS SUFFICIENT TO PAY
FOR ANY PROGRAM OR INCREASED A
SERVICE LEVEL. UNDER THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I SEE NO
QUESTIONERS COMMENTS WILL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES MISC INNER-
THANK YOU I ASKED FOR A VOTE. I
GET THAT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU. MISTER BRADFORD YEAH SB
SIX NINETY FOUR TO ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF A
MOTION- BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY A MISTER BRIAN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB SIX NINE
FOUR WHICH IS JUST A SIMPLE
MEASURE THAT ALLOWS
CONSERVATION CORPS WORKERS AND
FORMER INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTERS. THERE- THEY HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE EMPLOYED
WORKING IN WILDFIRE MITIGATION
WE KNOW THIS IS A GREAT.
CHALLENGE FOR MANY OF OUR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND I
THINK IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
GIVE THOSE FOLKS WITH THE
SKILLS THAT- EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
I THINK IT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX NINETY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE NINE NUMBER.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SB SIX NINETY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
CAN BE JUST A BRIEF MOMENT
LONGER. TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS JOHN LEVEL ALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION- THE CALIFORNIA-
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION COALITION-
OF PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
SUPPORT SERVICES ALL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS VERY GOOD SENSE BILL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY NOBODY IN
A REMOTE STATION FROM A FINANCE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FIVE
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT
IS RADFORD OTHER SAYS DRUGS
WILL COST TO THE STATE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S LONG OVERDUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
I SEE NO QUESTIONS AND I GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER BRADFORD THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO REGISTER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ANY BILL THAT IS
NOW IN THE SUSPENSE FILE WILL
GO THERE. OPERATOR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON ANY
OF THE BILLS YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
JUST A MOMENT BUT OUR FIRST MY
NUMBER. TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS JOHN LEVEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THE COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION- AND THAT COALITION
OF PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS OF
SUPPORT SYSTEMS- ALL IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL TWO
NINE SIX BY- SENATOR NAME ONLY
WHICH WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
SAFETY PROTECTIONS FOR OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS- ALL WITH
CREAM WEEKS WE COOLEY EXPECT
WITHIN EXISTING BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS I'M MORE HOPEFUL
BECAUSE BILL. WILL PREVENT
QUICKLY COME OFF LOOK THIS IS.
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO TAKE
SUPPORT I SUPPORT. I OPPOSE A
BILL. SIR ANALYST ALL RIGHT.
STEP THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER TWENTY FOUR YOUR I'M
SORRY YES MY TWENTY FOURTH THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR OUR
NUMBERS CHRISTOPHER'S MONSTERS
POLICY ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER
LONG PARTY WHERE PROPER
SPONSORED SB SIXTY TWO IN
LITERATURE. THAT OTHER AYE VOTE
WHEN IT COMES UP. OKAY AGAIN.
NOW BECAUSE I LET YOU GO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON A BILL THAT IS IT
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY NINE
CHAIR ZACHARY WARM OUT DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COLQUITT WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. I'M
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MATTHEW TO CARLESS OF THAT
SUBJECT LEGAL SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TIFFANY AB FROM FASHION
REVOLUTION US ANY COME STRONG
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO. MY
THE TWENTY SEVEN AT BEHIND OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T CARE
ACTIVISTS AND THE TEMPO FASHION
THE FOUNDER AND CREATIVE
DIRECTOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
JOE HUMAN FROM PASSION
EVOLUTION AND THAT'S FOR FOUGHT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE C.
SIXTY TWO. NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI BABY THEM DOLLARS WITH A
GARMENT WORKER CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK THERE'S- WITH
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY THAT ONCE
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
NOBODY ON THE- TV AD WITHOUT.
RECORD TIME WE ENDED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
EIGHTEEN MINUTES.